und jetzt ist folgendes passiert ich
habe mich geschrieben und gut hat mir
einen 400 euro angegeben
durch cash ich habe jetzt einfach 400
euro dein konstant 400 euro und die
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
ja ich habe natürlich geht es gut aber
das war mir grad bisschen schwindelig
ich will doch einfach nur entspannt
video drehen muss sich anstrengen
heute muss ich ehrlich nicht ich hoffe
natürlich geht's gut keine ahnung ob ich
das gerade schon gesagt habe ich habe
heute was wirklich wirklich
interessantes vor für mich ist es sehr
interessant viele von euch kennen
wahrscheinlich noch die videos damals
ich bestelle 100% zufällig auch wo ich
einige sachen auch wirklich bestellt
habe vieles habe ich das manchmal nicht
bestellt so das war ein bisschen würde
ich heutzutage gar nicht mehr machen
wobei ich schon vieles also gut das weiß
auch übertrieben es kommen jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen negativ über
also ich habe vieles von den sachen
nicht dann wirklich zufällig ermittelt
habe auch bestellt einige sachen ist 100
euro kostet haben vielleicht nicht immer
weil sie nicht mehr und jetzt ist
folgendes passiert ich habe eine gut
geschrieben und frisch hat mir einen 400
euro gutschein gegeben also ich habe
jetzt hier warte mal ich zeige euch das
jetzt mal so fort wir sind hier auf der
startseite kann man ja sehen und das
hier ist mein profil und wenn man jetzt
hier
ich habe jetzt einfach 400 euro dann
constant 400 euro ja hatte ich noch nie
und da habe ich mich wirklich sehr
darüber gefreut und ich habe mir gedacht
ich könnte eigentlich weil ich weiß ich
habe das noch nie gesehen dass bei
irgend einem youtuber hier ist dieser
bus konnte stand so bei 400 euro oder
generell halt irgendwie stand dass es so
etwas überhaupt gibt und deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht kannst du eigentlich ein
video drehen wie ich diese 400 euro
jetzt einfach aus gebe also safe will
ich jetzt halt alles ausgeben und wie
das halt an am ende funktioniert weil
die meisten leute
also wie ich ja eigentlich auch vor man
hockt sachen den wagen auf und bezahlte
danach mit paypal visa card nicht klar
also klar da ist bei mir unten durch
diese kacke da muss ich zwei waren
inkassoverfahren zahlen da wurden aus 20
euro 100 euro nur weil ich die nicht
gesehen hat weil ich halt so viel
bestellt hat ist ein anderes thema ich
würde sagen wir lara gar nicht lange und
fanden direkt mal an ich habe wirklich
einiges vor und ich baller das jetzt
einfach hintereinander rein
wir fallen auf jeden fall schon mal an
mit was ist das denn auch solche der
lamborghini
wir fangen auf jeden fall schon mal hier
mit angebauter unbedingt testen
israel ist das so ja diese originalen
bieterprozess kenne ich gar nicht aber
mir bestellen die einfach mal bin ich
mal gespannt was da ankommt kaufen
danke guck mal hier gibt es hier sogar
noch mal einen spaß
cool ride schwarz-weiß 14 euro nur rund
acht euro versandt wird immer jetzt habe
ich einen euro gespart was auch immer
das hier ist sieht interessant aus
weil einfach einfach mal mit rein dieses
mal dann was sie jetzt den blau der ich
will ihren spaß
warum kommt einen schuh wenn man eher
verzeihen gibt das musste mal einer
erklären also das ist eine sache die ich
hier auf keinen fall verstehen okay gut
mit diesen beiden sachen mit dir schon
mal zufrieden dann wollte ich auf jeden
fall noch bestellen iphone 11 gadget das
wollte ich immer schon mal gemacht haben
und iphone 11 ist halt das neueste
deswegen machen wollten
ich schaue mir das hier mal ganz kurz an
dass hier habe ich jetzt auch schon
öfter gesehen ich habe absolut keine
ahnung wer das braucht ja hier kann man
sein iphone laden während man die
airports steht während man all seine
smart watch lädt das motto das habe ich
natürlich auch viele alles nur so billig
zeug aber ich habe viele ich würde sagen
das nehme ich auf jeden fall mal mit
sieht interessant aus letzte ob alles
klar
genau wer kennt es nicht einfach auf die
apple ist kohlefaser spinning angeltour
habe ich mir schon immer gewünscht hier
gibt's das ganze dann noch für sechs
euro okay aber halt ohne airports
deswegen brauchen wir das nicht ohne
scheiß dass ihr nämlich auch mit einfach
weil es so verrückt aussieht da muss
erst mal eine darauf kommen dass hier
der eine unfassbar hilfreiche sache
einfach weil ich mit diesen ganzen
anschlüssen mittlerweile schon
durcheinander komme nämlich mit alter
und hier haben wir tatsächlich eine mini
powering ich habe noch nie so eine
kleine bauwerk gesehen deswegen nehmen
wir die natürlich auch mit werde eine
bestens lang also irgendwie bin ich hier
mittlerweile jetzt schon so war alter
von case led flash für das hatten das
mit einfach abzutun okay aber einfach
nichts komme ich auch dran dann nehmen
wir das mal in gold
okay das sieht irgendwie zu billig aus
in pink kommen pink lass mal pink nehmen
ging waren die leute was ich gerade
sagen wollte ich bin jetzt schon so weit
unten ich glaube hier kommt nichts mehr
deswegen muss ich mal was neues in die
suche eingeben
mai von 11 mal gucken was hier kommt
junge junge
es gibt sachen warum kommt es doch
island jacke
alte das sieht auch krank aus war das
nehme ich auch mal mit in roth ich frage
mich noch das leuchtet so wagt kurz
dazwischen schon dass es irgendwie echt
schwierig noch weiter zu finden wir
haben jetzt nach gerade mal 100 euro
da geht noch was ich wollte auf jeden
fall noch einen zweiten part machen von
airports cases aus aller welt
und deswegen wird es ganz ganz schnell
einen anderen in den warenkorb geballert
keine ahnung was auch immer ich hier
bekomme
wir nehmen einfach dazu die frage ist
natürlich auch immer nämlich dass für
die normalen erfolgs oder für die apps
pro bei mir ist es eigentlich egal
ich habe ja eh alles flex ok farbe weiß
ich bin irgendwie so ein fan von weiß-
oder indirekt vom das wahrzunehmen
ich bin irgendwie ein fan von schwarz
das hier ist halt einfach eine ikea tüte
oder so was ähnliches bin ich mal
gespannt was da ankommt okay hier haben
wir eine power bank in einem pokal alles
klar
nämlich auch mit hat er zwar nichts mit
airport cases zu tun aber egal wo das
ist halt wirklich krank leute also das
ist was extrem leises hier kaufe ich
direkt die wollen wir jetzt erzählen man
kann tatsächlich und schuhe der leuchtet
für einen euro kaufen das glaube ich
nicht aber ich habe ja eh nichts zu
verlieren ich kaufe es einfach mal
ich meine was sind schon ein euro von
400 euro denn hier habe ich schon dass
hier noch nicht tatsächlich so dass sie
kommt auch noch dazu lucky strike
smokings gilt ja genau das richtige für
mich bin mich so ein kranker raucher
also brauchen leute hört auf zu rauchen
war das hier das ist interessant die
nehme ich natürlich auch eine blaue das
könnte extrem gut aussehen vor allem es
passt auch sehr gut zu kleinen moment
hierzu da kann man mal schauen was mehr
leuchtet ihr könnt übrigens wenn man die
kommentare schreiben
dieses licht findet kommt dann nehmen
wir einfach noch hier eine mit weil es
so schön ist in ping okay leute sagen
drei noch dann reicht auch schon dann
habe ich schon wieder genug zeug
ach du scheiße kommt weil ich gerade
sowieso ein paar tik tok videos machen
oder ticker live hacks habt ihr ja
wahrscheinlich gesehen nehmen weil die
hier
den spaß natürlich auch noch mit ohne
scheiß mittlerweile schon so weit runter
gescrollt okay diese hier ist auch gut
brauchen natürlich okay drei euro kann
man machen so das reicht jetzt erstmal
kleider zwischenstand wir haben schon 21
paket in unserem warenkorb und wir haben
etwa 180 server verraten was soll ich da
noch bestellen
aber gut ich gebe natürlich nicht auf
wir gehen auch die startseite und
zweiten mal runter diese hier kann ich
auch noch nicht kopfhörer sind ja immer
extrem gut zum testen den schwarz 13
euro ja obwohl die habe ich schon drin
oder ach komm ich weiß es nicht
vielleicht habe ich die schon drin ich
bin mir nicht sicher die seen auf jeden
fall anders aus
die generation ausverkauft wie
ausverkauft jetzt ist aber gut oder gebt
euch mal diesem scheiß alles klar
da nehme ich nehme ich natürlich sehr
ganz klar so und hier haben was ich
jetzt aber wirklich ja new generation in
der farbe schwarz für 15 euro
ganz schön viel aber juckt mich nicht
kaufen
leute ich könnte das den ganzen tag
machen es ist wirklich interessant also
mir macht das richtig gut wägen wir uns
nicht spaß macht ich weiß gar nicht mehr
was ich suchen sollte smartphone wobei
es auch irgendwie ein bisschen
langweilig ist handys hatte ich schon
mal was brauche ich denn noch leute ich
habe eine klasse idee
ich kaufe jetzt einfach den teuersten
airport fake den ich hier finde was das
denn hier original auch mit logo drauf
noch oder wie junge wer braucht denn
sowas 49 euro mit angel wing wir hatten
ein kleines technisches problem und 240
minuten die aufnahme abgebrochen ich
habe das nicht mitbekommen deswegen
jetzt noch mal ganz schnell die produkte
die ich nicht mehr zeigen konnte im
schnelldurchlauf wir haben ihre youtube
produkte eine youtube taste einen
youtube oder youtube yahoo youtube
youtube pissen ja da habe ich einmal
hier dieses subscribe kissen gewählt
und einmal hier das schwarze youtube
hessen finde ich extrem leicht kann man
ganz einfach hier gut im hintergrund
stellen dann weiß auch jeder auf welcher
plattform ist und dann haben wir noch
iphone cases ganz wichtig weil ich ja
auch noch ein video zu drehen
wir haben hier so eine simson space wir
haben ja einen zu meinen freundinnen wir
haben 1 von nasa wir haben etwas gipfels
wir haben hier dieses dingen was auch
immer das sein soll
dann habe ich noch eine smart touch
bestellt dann fand ich so höchst
interessant auch mal so apple sex zu
testen wie zum beispiel diese apple maus
also ich hab mir selber so eine könnt
ihr sehen wo ja und ich glaube das war's
dann auch schon okay leute ich habe
jetzt gerade noch versucht hier so ein
promo code anzuwenden das ging irgendwie
nicht wir sind jetzt hier bei den - -
300 - 330 euro 25 die ich jetzt
bestellen werde
und dazu muss ich einfach nur drauf
drückend und jetzt werden einfach nicht
von seinem eigenen geld 330 euro 25 bild
zahlt also unsere stellen halt und ich
hoffe das funktioniert jetzt auch so wie
es mir gedacht habe 321 bahn perfekt
alter also ich glaube es ist so eine
teure klar das teuerste produkt zwar
teurer aber sonst habe ich noch nie für
so viel geld gleichzeitig bestellt
interessant ihr könnt es nochmal sehen -
330 euro zahlungsmethode ruhig bei
welchem user fast schon mal gesehen
ich glaube bei keimen oder leute
abonniert auf jeden fall meinen zweiten
kanal ist ganz oben in der beschaffung
von links alex baur tag kommen ganz ganz
viele videos jeden tag fast 1 reaktions
kanal auf jeden fall abonnieren
instagram alex wie und wir sehen uns
morgen um 20 uhr
ich hoffe natürlich die videos kommen
ende februar ende februar ende februar
bis mitte märz alle online
wir haben ja bestimmt zehn verschiedene
die wir hier drehen können und das war's
haut rein aber in den kanal